les ferchaud flora virer devant parce
qu'il faut pas le laisser partir la
ville et devant se retrouve dans la même
position les deux versants tribord amure
donc là un peu la configuration d'hyères
elles vont vers la ligne d'arrivée le
vin qui peut tomber si vous avez manqué
lorsque nous avons eu la vue
d'hélicoptère sous la boue et la bouille
ne bougeait pas tellement sa venue qui a
pas tellement de vent donc là elles sont
en train d'aller toutes les deux à tirer
des bords à sion contrôler faut pas
qu'il faut pas la laisser partir
tout ce que vous et orange va faire je
vais faire changement va faire là elle
est devant elle contrôle étroitement je
ne te lâche pas je vais avec toile
effectivement il ya une petite
différence de voyous mais bon on fait
l'expérience a retenu la leçon 10h je
pense est ici ce qu'il faut pas faire ne
faut pas laisser trop prendre au vent
faut le laisser comme il est comme elle
est sous le vent bien parce que quand on
laisse la boue et la voile laguiole
points devant sienne petite risée une
petite rafale
elle perd ce moment-là choqué la voix
les points au filet la voile dégager la
voie là
du bateau et prendre de la vitesse là je
pense qu'elles vont doigt sur la ligne
d'arrivée voilà j'ai fait un flop laisse
aucune chance à établissements rosette
orange puis à faire partir pour
remporter sa troisième victoire
le prologue dimanche à fort de france la
première étape aux halles et puis
maintenant le marais un leader qui est
peut-être y travaillent
un spectacle et qui ma foi de ses
champions va consolider sa place de
leader une nouvelle fois parce que
derrière il ya des écarts on l'a vu au
passage de la bouée à lens figi ignol
comme appétit était déjà plus de dix
minutes presque le raid en troisième
position également plus de 10 minutes et
puis ensuite j'en avais semaines peabody
energy
cinquième à plus de dix minutes rapide
mahaleo zalik un point concernant la
troisième viol brasserie lorraine alain
côté cabine où nous avons laissé donc
derrière sm thibout que d'énergie qui
passe également au village vacances que
vous connaissez très bien et nous sommes
juste derrière brasserie lorraine saraki
et comme on dit en fait j'aime beaucoup
cette expression est à dans la cuisine
j'ai appelé zapetti la cale aux à
project notation à l'aide
c'est l'arrivée c'est l'arrivée gens
plutôt belle arriver là si vous voulez
laguiole à le contrôler
on fait attention qu'il y en ait pas une
fois cela fall qui disent que le coût
des charges et lier qu on a le contrôle
on a su on a la victoire en poche la
ligne d'arrivée toupin n'est pas très
large elle est tout près on va y arriver
si no3 vue on va voir que les yeux
noisette ou rangés derrière bon vous
êtes aurenche et qu'elle a conçu perdu
voilà la ligne d'arrivée est là elle
sera franchie maintenant brillamment par
la loi lui ai fait un changement
félix mérine ses amis du robert semrau
mertens bon on fait une belle belle
belle compétition l etat beaux jours
c'est la 48e tu as vingt unième victoire
au laguiole ufr champ clos depuis le
lancement du modèle en deuxième position
de karachi est une belle victoire encore
pour sept viols fr chamfort en deuxième
position établissement vous êtes comme
hier du côté des hausses d'arles est
donc établi soit rosette/orange à
quelques longueurs 28 secondes pour
établissent fois rosette/orange mandat
les deux premiers rôles sont passés